HAMMERED VOTE DEMOCRAT?
HERSCHEL WALKER IS THE
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE IN GEORGIA.
SO, HERSCHEL WALKER, HOW DID
THAT SPEECH GO DOWN IN THE STATE
OF GEORGIA?
>> THAT SPEECH DIDN'T GO DOWN
THAT WELL AT ALL.
THE BIGGEST THREAT TO THE
DEMOCRACY IS JOE BIDEN BEING IN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
THE BIGGEST THREAT IN DEMOCRACY
IS SENATOR WARNOCK AND JOE BIDEN
HIGH INFLATION.
AND THAT'S A THREAT TO DEMOCRACY
RIGHT THERE THE BIGGEST THREAT
TO DEMOCRACY IS THE CRIME THAT
THEY HAVE LET COME ON THE
STREETS AND ALL OF THIS HAS LAND
AT LESS THAN OTWO YEARS THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN IN THE WHITE
HOUSE.
I THINK THAT'S SAD AND ONE
REASON TIME FOR A CHANGE CARE
ABOUT THIS COUNTRY THEY CARE
ABOUT THE PEOPLE AT ALL.
AND THEY ARE MAKING THAT EXCUSES
TRYING TO SCARE SCARE EVERYBODY.
NOT GOING TO HAPPEN ON MY WATCH.
I'M GOING TO FIGHT AND LET
PEOPLE KNOW THE TRUTH AND THE
TRUTH IS WE CAN GET LOWER TAXES
AND ENERGY INDEPENDENT AND WHAT
WE GOT TO DO IS QUIT LISTENING
TO PEOPLE JOE BIDEN AND SENATOR
WARNOCK.
>> Jesse: DO PEOPLE IN GEORGIA
KNOW HOW RADICAL LEFT WARNOCK
IS?
WE HAVE SHOWN SOME OF THESE
CLIPS.
THIS GUY IS A LUNATIC.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, THEY ARE
STARTING TO BECOME AWARE OF IT.
RIGHT NOW THAT'S THE REASON YOU
SEE THE POLLS ARE CHANGE IT.
KIDS.
CAMP.
AWARE OF.
HE IS UPSET NOW.
WELL, THEY ARE DOING IT TO HIM
BECAUSE IT'S TRUE.
YOU KNOW, I I HAVE BEEN VERY
TRANSPARENT ABOUT MY LIFE BUT I
WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW SENATOR
WARNOCK IS VERY RADICAL.
AFTER TWO YEARS SEE WHAT HE HAS
DONE TO THIS COUNTRY AND STATE
SIX MORE YEARS AND BEING A
PASTOR THAT'S LYING TO THE
PEOPLE BLOLD FACED LYING TO THE
PEOPLE HE CAN DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENT.
I SAID WHEN MAYA ANGELOU SAID
WHEN SOMEBODY SHOWS YOU WHO THEY
ARE, BELIEVE THEM.
AND WE HAVE GOT TO BELIEVE
SENATOR WARNOCK THAT'S EXACTLY
WHO HE IS AND WHAT IS HE DOING
RIGHT NOW.
>> WARNOCK DOES NOT HAVE A
HEISMAN TROVE.
>> HE NEVER WON A HEISMAN TROPHY
AND I DON'T THINK HE CAN EVER
WIN A HIZMAN TROPHY.
HE DID A COMMERCIAL WHERE HE WAS
RUNNING TRACK AND RUNNING ON THE
TRACK BACKWARDS.
NOT ONLY IS HE VOTING BACKWARDS
IS HE RUNNING ON THE TRACK
BACKWARDS AS WELL.
AND THAT'S ONE BE THING THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT ME
BEING AN ATHLETE.
NOW, GUYS, I'M NOT THE ATHLETE.
I CREATED A BUSINESS.
SO I SIGNED IN FRONT OF A
PAYCHECK AND I DON'T THINK THEY
HAVE EVER DONE THAT I HAVE DONE
THE THINGS IT TAKES TO BE A GOOD
SENATOR.
I THINK AFTER THAT DEBATE I
THINK EVERYONE SAW WHO WAS THE
TRUE SENATOR IT WAS HERSCHEL
WALKER.
>> Jesse: CLOSE RACE DOWN THERE
IN GEORGIA NECK AND NECK.
TURN OUT BIG.
HERSCHEL WALKERRER THANKS FOR
COMING ON "PRIMETIME."
>> TELL EVERYONE TO BECOME A
PART OF TEAM HERSCHEL.COM.
WIN THE SEAT FOR THE GREAT
PEOPLE OF GEORGI